having a purpose that transcends
yourself is really important in terms of
your own mental health your physical
health your longevity and if you're
striving for something that is not
authentic for you and is very externally
validated that causes disease in the
system you know and it can literally
make you sick or it can just make you
unhappy and what happens in that
scenario is that you may achieve the
amount of money that you want to earn or
the place that you want to live deep
down you're not actually happy so
finding out what it is that will truly
make you happy and I'm not even really
saying that you know like being super
happy all the time is is the goal it's
the thing that means that you are the
person that you're meant to be they're
not completely selfish things that you
are absolutely flourishing in gratitude
which means that you know the the
bonding hormones and the feelings of
trust and Joy are um you know going
around your blood and and impacting your
immune system in a positive way and
really allowing you to be the best
version of yourself that you can be hey
it's EV car Michael and I make these
videos because I want to wake up and
feel like today is going to matter that
I can do something special and the way
that I get that feeling is I see people
who are doing amazing things and in
watching them say amazing things and do
amazing things it makes me feel like I
can do amazing things too so I hope that
this video helps you feel like you can
do something amazing today as well so
today let's get some incredible
motivation from the one and only Tara
swart enjoy
I do a digital detox for 1 to four weeks
around the holidays period and that
completely resets me and makes me feel
so revitalized and creative and
re-energized for January
onwards um but I will back that up by
saying I don't do big New Year's
resolutions anyway so I take the Year by
quarters so we've roughly got a quarter
of this year left and I'll change two or
three habits like I always say change 10
things by 1% rather than one thing by
10% so I'll have Incorporated a few
habits across the year already and I'll
just be trying to add in another two or
three now but the main way to reinvent
myself is the digital detox on a
practical level what does that look like
how do you get ready for it and then
when you're doing it how do you choose
to set boundaries around digital devices
and unation so I it's actually a lot
about preparing other people because
people find it kind of a bit threatening
and abandoning I found like over the
years so I will have an outof office
notice and it's very clear I will not be
reading my emails until mid January um
I'll reply to you after that and you
said that even before I'll set so let's
say I'm doing mid December to mid
January then I'll I'll have set that up
to start in mid December and it will
very clearly say I won't even read your
email until mid January so so that
people don't think oh maybe she's read
it but she hasn't replied yet or um and
it gives them the option as well then if
they want to remind me in mid January
about something um and if they had a
time in mind let's say they wanted me to
do something in early January that they
would know that I'm I'm genuinely not
going to see that request till um I get
back I do have a you know email my
assistant if it's there's Like Ur an
urgent inquiry
but then she also has like a set of
boundaries in terms of what she would um
contact me for or not and and I
literally switch my phone off so I would
not receive WhatsApp text messages
emails phone calls if you're suffering
in grief or stress or loss
or
scarcity that let's say it was you and I
and you know it was just friends that if
I process that really differently
emotionally and you're going on your
journey with the same thing that we've
both experienced it's really hard to be
there for each other because not only
are you already struggling with your own
emotions but if they're very different
to your friends or your partners then
it's hard for you to put yourself in
their position you know that phrase put
yourself in their shoes I always say put
yourself in their brain but that is hard
to do like it's it's hard to do at the
best of times it's really hard to do if
you're compromised by stress
because when you are
stressed we go at the other end from
oxytocin so then we have this hormone
cortisol and one of the ways that
cortisol helps you to get through stress
is it changes the where the blood flow
in your brain goes so it brings it down
to just survival mode like what do I
need to do today to just get through
this day
minimum it doesn't allow the blood to
flow to the parts of your brain that
allow you to be creative or think f
flexibly or think out of the box so it
just really shuts down your thinking
when you need it the most and that's why
it's important to like be mindful of
like keeping up your resilience and
doing things like journaling and
mindfulness which we can come to later
how can people begin to attract um the
life that they want to bring abundance
into your life you have to be
cultivating an abundant mindset and so a
really easy way to start is to list the
things that you're grateful for that you
already
have and as part of attracting things
into your life or
manifestation there are various
techniques like visualization or vision
boards um but part of it is you know
imagine it being true imagine what it
would look like feel like smell like and
then when you have that Vision in your
mind give gratitude for it becoming true
so then you know it sets you on a path
of I'm grateful for the things that I've
got these are the things that I want
want um and you know you're staying
positive and abundant and grateful and
that's much more likely to attract those
good things into your life also to make
sure you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there
every experience that your brain has
which me you have so like literally
every memory that you recall every
emotion that you experience every person
that you meet every scenario that you're
in is constantly molding and shaping
your brain so um because of a field of
research about
neuroplasticity we understand how much
more flexible and impressionable the
brain is throughout our
lives this may start to change I don't
even want to use the word decline you
know around the age of 70 where
sometimes things like sequential
memories can become a bit disordered but
our wisdom and judgment becomes like a
superpower
so it it can change towards the end of
life but really throughout most of our
working life let's say um the brain is
very open to being changed by everything
that it
experiences and the longer that an
impression has been held in the brain
the more deeply embedded it is into our
neural architecture so particularly
things that we experienced from the age
of n to 7 but also 7 to 14 and then
onwards but you know those periods
really because they're the longest ago
and if you had a repeated experience or
a highly emotional experience then those
are the two main reasons that things get
imprinted into your brain repetition and
strong emotion the parental expectation
societal
expectation how competitive your school
was the kind of people that you hung
around with words that were used about
you when you were a kid those things
they run deep in your brain and they
like you said they do affect your
perception of everything else that
happens in your adult life and you know
one of the
main areas of work around that is what's
called Shadow work and psychology which
is the things that you perceived as a
child would mean that you wouldn't be
loved and looked after by your main
caregivers so those sorts of things
whether it's like oh you know stop
showing off or stop running around like
that those things get put into your
Shadow like you know I mustn't talk
highly of myself I mustn't you know sort
of like do things at speed if other
people can't keep up those are the
things we try to hide about ourselves
and usually around the age of midlife
crisis or whatever you want to call it
you know those things can really like
come up and have to be dealt with and
integrated that most of the
neuroscientists that I know all the ones
I know personally and other ones that
I've heard of don't watch the news or
read newspapers that's powerful and it's
not because we don't want to be informed
because obviously we do manage to stay
informed in other ways of important
events around the world but if you just
look at the nature of news the the
proportion of it that is bad news and
the impact that that has on your brain
is is
disproportionate so the first thing is
to curate your news feeds your social
media feeds so that you're not getting
bombarded with so much bad news and and
you balance that out for yourself
of course life can be hard so yes you
have to be resilient as well but the
first thing is to take charge of of what
you're actually feeding your brain and
that's everything from your diet to
information if I could give people a
takeaway to start with that's really
simple but it doesn't mean there isn't a
lot of hard work at the other end of it
it would be be very clear on what it is
that you want so you've mentioned a few
things spend 5 minutes sitting down and
visualizing those things being
true and then give gratitude for that
that would be my first
step give gratitude for those things
being
true just five minutes I'm a great
partner I'm not messy my podcast is
super
successful like see it feel it in your
body taste it in your mouth hear it in
your ears completely immerse yourself in
that 5 minutes minutes longer if you can
and then
just be so grateful for all of that
essentially what you're doing is moving
your brain from a fear state to a trust
State and that is the gateway to making
these changes I wrote the book every
weekend for a year and that was a great
part of my journey of integrating those
things doing the research finding out
what science could explain the laws of
attraction but then actually it was the
response to the book that I think really
hit me emotionally that how much people
wanted a very clear
pragmatic explanation of what you have
to do with your brain and your thinking
and your feeling and your action to
bring the things that you want into your
life so I'll start with visualization um
and vision boards I kind of the science
behind them is is quite similar so it's
basically about three processes that
happen in the brain and they are
selective filtering selective attention
and value tagging so basically we're
bombarded with so much information and
this has been the case for a long time
but if you read a copy of the New York
Times
today you would receive as much
information from that one newspaper as
somebody would in their entire lifetime
a 100 years ago and even then they were
overly bombarded with information so the
brain has a natural um filtering
mechanism which is that you don't have
need to notice things that aren't really
relevant to your survival so for example
you don't notice your clothes on your
body all day um so we need to direct
that filtering system
otherwise in a way we're still wired
just to survive and
reproduce so things that will help us to
thrive in the modern world may not
necessarily be filtered in unless we're
presenting visual images to our brain on
a daily basis or sitting down and
closing our eyes and you know
visualizing the things that we want in
our life or a certain outcome if we do
those
practices then the next process comes in
which is selective attention which is
that you notice the things that you're
visualizing or you have on your vision
board it's like when you buy a new car
and then you suddenly see it
everywhere um so it's basically priming
your brain to notice opportunities that
will take you closer to your goals and
then value tagging is the brain's system
of putting things in order of importance
and it does this in two ways it does it
in a cold or logical way and a warm or
emotional way so The Logical things are
basically the survival you know the
basics that we need to survive like roof
over our head food on the table um and
the warmer things are the ones that we
might choose to put on our vision board
so they're the things you know our
dreams our desires goals that show that
we're thriving rather than just kind of
you know surviving so by repeatedly
exposing your brain to these images
you're priming it to not just notice but
also grasp the opportunities that will
take you closer to what you want and
that's why I call vision boards action
boards because I don't believe that you
can create this fantasy image and sit at
home and wait for it to come true I
believe that you need to be out there
networking dating whatever it is um to
get the things that you want what are
the things that we can do to improve our
brain
performance so we talk about things
like rest which is sleep and also sort
of downtime nutrition is super important
so the brain is obviously a tiny
proportion of your body weight um and
only weighs a few kilos but it uses up
up to 30% of the breakdown products of
what you eat so when you're asleep your
brain is is eating up 20% of what you
ate that day when you're at work um and
focused on something it's using up about
a quarter of what you eat and when
you're stressed it's using up up to 30%
oh wow yeah and so obviously people
think what should I eat if I want to be
healthy generally or I want to lose
weight or I want to build muscle mass
but the sorts of people that you know
like you and the people that I work with
aren't thinking enough about what should
I be eating so I can make the best
decisions today what should I be eating
so I can solve complex problems what
should should I be eating so I can
understand what's going on like in terms
of interpersonal Communication in my te
with my team for
example and then there's everything from
hydration
exercise um breathing mindfulness
curiosity like there's there's so many
factors that contribute to brain health
and they're probably not dissimilar to
things as a doctor that you would know
contribute to cardiovascular health or
gastrointestinal Health
but you know we at Heights feel that if
you approach everything with a brain
care first attitude then you're kind of
taking care of the rest of the stuff
like if you eat and drink in a way
that's good for your brain your skin and
your hair are going to look nicer I mean
and I that's sounds like such a girly
thing to say but people make a lot of
really important choices based on what
they look like and and and that's fine
and that probably has like beneficial
effects on our you know our brains and
our guts as well but considering this
organ is so so energy hungry and it's so
important in terms of everything else
that happens in your body I feel like we
need to flip that narrative so that it's
starting with okay what can I what
things can I do today that are going to
be the best for my brain intuition Falls
a lot
between physical and
emotional so the emotional centers of
the brain are deep inside the brain and
they're the size of your clenched fist
so you know yours is slightly bigger
than mine but it's proportional for your
body and then around that about the same
thickness we have the cortex which has
more of the logical Pathways of the
brain and because you can't remember
everything that you've experienced in
your whole life
but everything that you've experienced
has had an impression on your brain body
system we believe that we keep our
working memory up here these are the
things we need to remember every day to
do our job and live our life and then
through a process called heavan learning
which is named after the neuroscientist
Donald Hebb and is really simply
explained by neurons that fire together
wire together we believe that our wisdom
and our pattern recognition get pushed
deeper and deeper into the brain into
the spinal cord and even into our gut
neurons and that's why intuition is
sometimes called gut instinct so
basically the lessons that you've picked
up in life the wisdom that you've
learned through repeated patterns that
could be as deeply held in your your
neurons as like deep down in your G so
you're not conscious of it but it still
guides the the decisions that you
make now what I've found over the last
10 years or so particularly the 10 years
I've been teaching at MIT Sloan which is
Business Leaders is that people would
really rely on their logic and say
things like well you know I'm not going
to make a really important decision like
H or fire on intuition because you know
that's not is it even a thing as we been
able to scan brains and learn more about
how these neurons connect up and store
information I really see particularly
the older generation of leaders saying
that is absolutely the main way that I
will make my most important decisions
and I'm I'm like that you know I will
make my most important life decisions
based on intuition and the way that I
have helped myself to understand how
much that is the right thing for me is
through journaling so if I journal and
I'm I'm writing like you know what
should I do in this situation my gut's
telling me this but logic tells me that
or my emotions tell me something else I
basically plot out how things pan out
depending on which modality I use to
make my decision once I discovered
neuroplasticity I thought I wish I'd
known about this when I was 18 really
you know it's literally life-changing I
think I was naturally manifesting from
about the age of 18 anyway but I didn't
understand the science behind it once
you understand that you can literally
change your brain at any stage any age
any
mindset that's like it's lifechanging
isn't it and and I feel that you know
one of the things we were sort of
chatting about earlier is that just
because I'm a scientist and an MD it
doesn't mean that in my real life it's
easy for me to just Channel
neuroplasticity it's still it's still
hard you know I've been through a
divorce I've been through grief I've
been through career change and those
hard times taught me resilience and
neuroplasticity but the hard times were
almost the opportunity I didn't want to
go through those things I don't want you
know our listeners to go through hard
times yeah pain but you can take that as
an opportunity and I think if you really
understand neuroplasticity then you can
make the worst times in your life the
start of the best time in your life and
that's what I love about neuroplasticity
that it's that ability to change to grow
to regulate your emotions which I know
you're really into and and build
resilience I mean an example of
neuroplasticity that I would share with
with with you with our listeners is
gratitude lists so for years in my
journaling I would write 10 things I'm
grateful for every day and they were
always external things friends family
travel you know um Financial Freedom
whatever and I literally just got bored
of writing the same thing so I thought
okay what what else could I write so I
started writing things like my
creativity my vulnerability my
resilience internal things and that was
a real game Cher really what happened
when you started doing that it made me
think that whatever life throws at me
I've got the tools and resources within
me to deal with it um and and I didn't
always have you know in my 20s I
wouldn't say I was very emotionally
regulated um but learning that
whatever happens the the sort of the
pendulum swing for your emotions the
higher it goes the lower it goes as well
and and bringing that to like parameters
that you're comfortable with is that
gives you sort of autonomy and agency in
life sure um and and again that's the
thing I love about neuroplasticity
abundance is basically about thinking
positively it's about believing that the
world is a good place that there's
enough out there for every everyone that
we're not in competition for resources
and that if somebody else does well that
doesn't mean badly for us that if we
give something to someone or help
someone with something that that's a
good thing that it generates more
positivity and that somehow you know the
you that that will come back to you at
some point and interestingly it um
correlates to the strongest gearing of
the brain that we have for our survival
as a species which is called loss
aversion yeah
so um that means that the psychological
effect of avoiding loss is about twice
as powerful as the psychological effect
of the equivalent gain or reward and the
easiest way to explain that is um if you
walked from the parking lot to your
studio this morning and
you found $50 on the floor on your way
in you'd be probably pleasantly
surprised that you found $50 you might
keep it you might give it to charity um
but by the time you you know you're in
the studio and you've started thinking
about recording you would have forgotten
about that
$50 if you walked from your car across
the parking lot and realized by the time
you got to the studio that you'd lost
$50 out of your pocket you'd be mad at
yourself you'd go back out to the the
parking lot to see if you could find it
you might even go back out there more
than once to check and you might still
be thinking about that at the end of the
day so that's just an example of how the
same loss or gain has more powerful
effect if we lose and so
psychologically um anything like feeling
excluded or isolated or treated unfairly
or feeling like you don't have the same
opportunities as somebody else has that
really strong effect on your on your
brain um and so we have to work doubly
hard to go against that because it is
something that helped us to survive in
evolution but
it's I was going to say it's not helpful
in the modern world but to be honest I
will say it's not a way to live a life
um you know it's a
very because I believe the way you think
determines your life if you believe that
everybody's out there in competition
there isn't enough out there for
everyone that you've got to like fight
to get your bit a strong negative
motivator gets us into action um
sometimes a really strong positive one
will do that too but not as strongly as
a negative motivator so I'm thinking for
example when I had my wedding come up
and I wanted to look a certain way and
for the whole wedding to feel a certain
way I did a lot of things I wouldn't
normally do to try to make sure that
happened but that was unusual and I
remember thinking then okay this is a
really positive motivator but most of
the time we do things to avoid a
perceived loss or we do things because
things have gone wrong for us and we
need to try to make it better and
actually that is very explained by
science because one of the strongest
gearings of our brain from evolution is
called loss avoidance and the brain is
two to two and a half times as primed to
avoid loss as it is to get a reward I
want everyone to know how much potential
they have in their brains and it is this
thing called neuroplasticity which is
the fact that the brain remains flexible
throughout our lives and so it is the
reason that we can change the way that
we think the way that we behave the
things that we believe the relationship
patterns that we have at any age at any
stage of life and with any mindset so
even if you are one of those skeptical
people that thinks you know you can't
teach teach an old dog new tricks or a
leopard can't change its spots or I'm
not going to change now this is the way
that I've always
been please just take away just put like
a seed into your brain this idea that
actually you can change I mean it's the
reason that I was telling you my podcast
is called reinvent yourself with Dr Tara
because you literally can change you
just have to want to and there is this
amazing ability of the brain to make new
connections overwrite old Pathways even
to grow like baby cells into like fully
formed cells and like create whole new
Pathways in your brain and all of that
underwrites your beliefs your thoughts
and your actions and those are the three
things that make your life what it is
basically rest means adequate length and
quality of
sleep now human brains 98 to 99% of them
anyway need to sleep for 7 to 9 hours
per night this is because there's a very
active cleansing process that goes on in
the brain overnight flushing out the
toxins from our met Metabolism from
stress from processed food from alcohol
antibiotics Etc and cleaning out those
pathologies like um beta amid plaques
and Tangles and Tow proteins that build
up to form the symptoms of dementing
diseases like Alzheimer's and
Parkinson's later in life so you do have
to take a really long-term view on this
and it's quite hard to identify as the
older person that will one day be so
it's important to think about the
day-to-day differences that not sleeping
enough can make if you have any sleep
disruption overnight you're operating
effectively with an IQ loss of 5 to
eight points the next day now for most
people this won't be noticeable but if
you lose a whole night sleep through
stress travel or sickness it actually in
population Norm studies lowers the IQ uh
by one standard deviation which for all
of us would mean that we are at the
level of a learning disability and I
really noticed this in myself when I'm
jet lagged for example so keep an eye on
your sleep if you don't have enough
sleep for four days in a row you build
up a debt of sleep that you can't make
up for by napping or lying in at the
weekends try to remember with sleep you
can always be in debt but you can never
be in credit however having said that
it's not healthy for all sorts of
physical reasons like cardiovascular
risk to sleep for more than 9 hours per
night one of the things about being
conscious and not being on autopilot is
is basically controlling what you expose
your brain to because the more you
expose it to bad news the more you're
likely to live life through fear we know
for example that people who repeatedly
looked at images of the Twin Towers
going down who had no personal
connection to New York could get PTSD I
mean it's it's incredible that just
exposing yourself repeatedly to bad news
especially with visual imagery can
actually traumatize you in a way that
you know you can't easily get over so
I'm very very careful about what I look
at what I read um you know my social
media feeds are carefully controlled to
be as positive as possible um you're
absolutely right that if you don't think
about it and you look at bad news just
before you go to sleep then think about
young children you've got young children
even if they you know read a book that's
not that scary but maybe has some
monsters in it then they can have
nightmares they can feel frightened um
so yeah everything that we expose our
brain to has an impact and we need to be
much more mindful of that um especially
because the gearing of the brain it's
two to two and a half times more likely
to focus on negatives than positives so
we need to be feeding our brain more
positive things to keep ourselves
confident um and you know moving forward
positively what are some steps that
somebody can take to begin to like
rewire some of these negative thought
patterns whether it's I'm not enough
this is is never going to happen I'm not
good enough so that they can have their
actions aligned with their thoughts
great question and you know there is a
lot of that negative selft talk around
and it's important to understand for a
start that that's normal that everybody
has that kind of thought or like periods
of time where they may have more of
those types of thoughts and it's quite
hard when you're already in that
negative spiral to really try to turn it
around um I want to get back to
resilience in in a while because your
podcast is called the adversity
Advantage so we should also speak about
what to do when you know it feels like
nothing's happening or things have gone
wrong but let's say you know it's a
regular day and sometimes it crosses
your mind that that kind of you know
goal is not going to happen for you
doesn't happen to people like me or
that's for kind of you know other people
so when you have a recurring negative
thought there's usually a very firmly
held belief underneath it that drives
that thought so you know it could be to
do with worthiness
deservingness
um and so it's important for people to
kind of dig underneath the recurring
negative thought and ask themselves what
is it that I must believe about myself
to keep having that thought and often
it's very non-conscious because it may
come from childhood and you know that
pathway has been there for so long that
you're not even aware of it if you can
do the journaling or the therapy or the
self reflection to understand what the
belief is that's driving your thought
then you can create a positive
affirmation or a mantra that's the
opposite statement to that belief and
you can repeat that every time you have
the thought so that you're basically
trying to overwrite that pathway in your
brain with this new more positive
thought and and that's an interesting
one because in the brain you can't undo
what's already wired in there you have
to overwrite it or replace it with
something that you you'd prefer
neuroplasticity is the ability of the
brain to grow and change and you see
that very clearly in children from Zer
to two where they go from being
completely helpless and vulnerable to
walking talking managing their own
bowels and Bladers pretty incredible um
there's a lot of change that goes on
during the teenage years as well it's
more pruning away of neural Pathways
that you don't need anymore and
Readiness for socialization and
reproduction and then we used to think
that that process really slowed down or
became quite passive from 25 to 6 well
we used to think from 18 now we know
it's very active till
25 and what we also know is that if you
do things to keep your brain flexible it
you can make changes absolutely from 25
to 65 and maybe even beyond that so I
believe that manifestation is
neuroplasticity the process is is
underly um by neuroplasticity which is
that you
have a certain way of thinking Behavior
patterns
habits and the more you repeat them and
the more emotional intensity is
associated with them the stronger those
Pathways become things that your peers
do impact you so it's not literally like
oh you know Jane got divorced so I'm
going to get divorced it's if there were
underlying problems in your marriage but
nobody in your social groups divorced
you you're going to just bury it and
keep going right as soon as somebody
else gets divorced you might think well
actually they've been brave to leave
their marriage and my marriage isn't
really you know as great as I say it is
when we're all out to dinner
together and you look at this person you
see them you know be brave move on maybe
meet somebody you know that's more on
their level and that makes you think
that that could be the outcome for you
and it you know absolutely doesn't have
to include them meeting someone else it
could just be that not being in that
relationship is is better for them and
if you identify with that it might just
give you the confidence and the courage
to make that step that you wouldn't have
made um so it probably usually takes
somebody who cannot tolerate being in
their relationship anymore to give
permission almost for people who kind of
were you know on the on the fence to say
actually I think it might be better for
me to to leave this marriage and so um
weight is another one I mean you rarely
see a group of friends where um you know
everybody's kind of at a average weight
and one person's really obese or one
person's like super skinny or vice versa
you rarely see a group of friends who
are all overweight with one friend who's
of you know average weight so um what
tends to happen is that if you feel a
bit of societal pressure to stay in a
certain shape because of the people that
you hang around with if they all start
putting on weight then it's kind of okay
for you two um and you know most people
put on weight in the pandemic right and
there was a definite kind of camaraderie
from saying oh my goodness I put on so
much weight because of like the stress
or because we're eating like you know so
well at home or you know we're eating
more junk or whatever it was um people
could connect with each other because a
lot of people put on weight during the
pandemic and there were definitely be
groups of friends that once that was you
know behind us to whatever extent it is
would just say well you know this is the
weight I am now and they'd all say yeah
you know me too um that's not going to
change now at our age and but you know I
was definitely in the group of friends
that were all like we need to get back
to our pre pandemic weight you know um
so of course you're influenced by the
people around you because if nobody else
around me said I want to get back to my
prepandemic weight maybe I would have
let it slide I don't know um but I
wasn't in that group so for me that
didn't happen but for a lot of people it
would have okay you're not taking a step
and action towards your like action
board goals but it's not really that
different to why you procrastinate over
you know a document or an interview or
something like that and it is because
you think it's going to be much harder
than it is and so I have so many
examples of where I finally get around
to something at the last moment and then
I think oh that didn't take as long as I
thought it wasn't as hard as I thought
um and I have a kind of let's say a
cousin question to to the two that we've
already said which is what would it feel
like if I get the best possible result
in this
scenario um and once you kind of just
imagine that and then you go into the
scenario you go in like so much more
willingly without the fear it's a
natural survival mechanism in our brain
to expect the worst to protect ourselves
from you know potential bad
consequences but particular particularly
in the modern world the proportion of
how often we think that's going to be a
bad outcome and what actually is is it's
skewed it's not correct so by priming
your brain more towards the trust and
excitement and getting the bonding
hormone going you feel better and the
fact is that your fear of how bad the
outcome could be wasn't correct in the
first place anyway so it aligns more
with reality so in the last
25 years or so we have had much more
sophisticated brain scanning technology
which shows how the brain works prior to
that we really understood a lot of how
the brain works from seeing what happens
when it goes wrong so if somebody has a
stroke or a brain tumor or a brain
injury once we could scan healthy brains
we started to learn a lot more about
this concept of neuroplasticity which is
that the brain grows and changes
throughout life now you've got two
little girls so you will know that from0
to two they went from being completely
vulnerable and helpless to walking
talking being able to control their
bladder and bowels and you know maybe
even speaking several languages and
having an opinion so it's a massive
burst of neuroplasticity and we see that
you know very visibly in young
children um around the teenage years
there's some pruning of the brain to
sophisticate it for adulthood for sexual
behavior emotional and social
interaction and that is quite an active
process till we're about 2 we used to
think it stopped when we physically St
stopped growing around the age of 18 but
the really interesting area for us in
manifestation and the laws of attraction
is that from 25 to 65 you can do things
that keeps your BL brain more plastic or
flexible and you can change the ways
that you think feel and act so to me
neuroplasticity underlies manifestation
and it's a four-step process it starts
with raised awareness so you need to
know what you want to bring into your
life or how you want your life to look
or feel um then it's focused attention
which is
noticing maybe you know negative
thinking or certain behaviors or
relationship patterns that are holding
you back from getting what you want and
also
noticing opportunities to get the things
that you want but really just building
up your database of okay that doesn't
work for me when I do this then you know
good things come into my life the third
part is deliberate practice so that is
going out there and doing the things
that you need to to manifest the things
that you want into your life got to do
the work got to do the work totally um
and the fourth part isn't really like a
step in the process but it's
accountability because it's very easy to
start particularly a new year and say
okay these are all my resolutions and
new things that I'm going to do and then
for most of us that motivation doesn't
you know remain
partly from the Neuroscience that's
because we tend to pick goals that are
too big and it's better to break them
down into bite-sized chunks and that's
the same for manifestation take small
steps towards the things that you want
so if there are some things that are
more in your control like getting fit
and healthy then start doing that and
then if there's something that's less in
your control like getting married or
having a baby then give that a bit
longer but know that you are changing
your brain by changing your behaviors
and you know have some form of
accountability whether it's a vision
board whether it's your partner whether
it's a therapist we've developed an
appreciation for things that we may have
taken for granted before so I have been
um in lockdowns I've been with one other
person and it has certainly made me
think at first I was like well if I'd
been on my own I would have been fine
but as the months drag on and as it
happens again and again I just my heart
just is so so out there for people
who've been through that on their own
that is not a healthy state for us and
so a lot of the work I've done in the
last year is to encourage people to
bathe rather than shower because
immersing yourself in warm water
releases the same bonding hormones that
you get from physical affection from a
loved one to massage your own body to do
gratitude practices that involve
self-touch um so a lot more you know
being a lot more proactive about the
fact that you may be been isolated alone
but also even with one affectionate
person or you know two or three
affectionate people in your family it's
normal in a day to go out and shake
hands or hug or kiss like eight to 12
people and so that happens and you don't
even really think about it and they say
that you need eight hugs a day just to
sort of stay mentally stable and 20 hugs
a day to grow as a you know as a person
who feels healthy and happy and they can
take some risks so I think suddenly
demanding 20 hugs a day from one person
is probably you
know you were talking about patience and
you know consistency is key to to
changing and growing
but that you know people have setbacks
or they they default to their old ways
of Behaving and it's also important to
say that that's normal and if that
happens that doesn't mean you should
give up but it just means you have to
start again so instead of wasting time
beating yourself up about the fact that
you didn't go to the gym or do the thing
that you were going to do just give
yourself a bit of a break and then start
start over again with whatever that
process is and so and so you've now
asked a question about something bigger
than that which is that you know
someone's really in a bad place life is
not good
and the feeling I got when you were
talking you know giving examples of that
situation is one of the worst feelings
in the world is when you feel like you
can't trust yourself anymore you know
you can't trust your Intuition or you
can't trust
your ability to get get yourself out of
these difficult situations I spent many
years working on mental resilience with
people um and emotional regulation was
part of that and that became important
again in the pandemic because we were in
like closed quarters with people and you
know and it was just very different and
it was hard and it was home schooling
and working and
everything um what I've seen as some of
the good things I've seen as a result of
the pandemic is that we've definitely
appreciated again the importance of our
time in
nature um so I think most of us felt
that that you know being able to get out
and be somewhere green was really
important and because there was like no
planes and no traffic you know we could
see the stars in the sky again we saw
amazing sunsets we people began to
appreciate bird song and now now the
studies are showing that time spent in
nature actually has a really positive
impact on your physical health your
mental health and your longevity so you
know that's one good thing that's come
out of it but are we all still you know
making time for that or are we just
going back to kind of our old ways what
does the Neuroscience or evidence say
around why journaling is
legit yeah so um at the very minimum
it's like a download of your emotions
and so with your you know any
emotions uh negative thoughts unfinished
tasks if you keep them in your brain
body system by just thinking about them
in your mind then you actually increase
your cortisol levels and cortisol
correlates with stress so it's like it's
like a pressure cooker building up if
you speak it out loud write it out into
a journal or do physical exercise and
literally sweat out some of that
cortisol then you're releasing those
negative emotions negative thought
patterns anxieties you know worries
about the future from your brain body
system but I have and I'd love to know
if you've done this or not I have I had
an Insight which I just stumbled across
by myself but it really makes sense
obviously from the neuroplasticity point
of view is that if you go back and read
over your Journal you see your thought
process laid out in front of you you see
your patterns of behavior you see like
your decision making tools whether it's
more logical or more intuitive you see
what you've written about your
relationships with people and seeing
that in your own handwriting or you know
even if has been synced up and and typed
out for you just just seeing knowing
that it's your words and what you've
thought and what you've said you can't
run away from that so it can be like so
insightful and enlightening and and I've
had that definitely with all of that
stuff like emotions and thought patterns
and intuition but I also had it when I
was I used to go to Boston twice a year
to teach MIT and I remember with the
travel and the jet lag just feeling that
I was having these small muscular
twitches and it was noticeable in bed at
night
and I decided to read back over not for
that reason but just anyway I decided to
read back over my journal from 6 months
earlier when I was last in Boston and
I'd written in my journal I'm getting
these little muscular twitches and so I
worked out that I'd become magnesium
deficient by flying and so I basically
hence why I was carrying so many bottles
of things with me when I was traveling
really upped my dose of magnesium um for
the trips and it never happened again oh
wow and if I hadn't read back I would
never put two and two together I would
have thought it was just happening now
and it hadn't happened before I try to
do the right things about sleep and
everything else but I don't get stressed
about it if I can't yeah um so that's
that's a really big thing for me you
know I try to eat right I try to
remember to take my supplements I
Journal when I can I meditate when I can
um but if I don't do it then I I don't
get stressed I would say that is a
really big learning for me I think that
that's a really big tip I would also say
it's better to change 10 things by 1%
than try to change one thing by 10% so
work on micro tweaks to your routine
like go to bed half an hour earlier do a
digital detox over one weekend um drink
a bit more water than you normally do
try to increase your steps by 1 to 2,000
per day for a week and see what happens
so small things like that build up
because you start to feel better your
brain becomes more powerful
and then you're able to do you know some
of the bigger goals that you may have
been saving up how does someone build
neuroplasticity in the brain and then
how does someone attempt to do that in
these times what are the best ways
and well I mean in a way what we've been
through in the year is a is an
opportunity to build neuroplasticity I
mean I know there was a sort of argument
online kind of last March or April which
was that there were a lot of people
people saying okay I'm going to have a
few months off and I'm going to start up
a new business or I'm going to like you
know learn a new language and some
people were very angry about this
because it you know put a lot of
pressure on people to to do new things
and not just do the minimum or not just
kind of you know do what they had to to
survive and and I was very much in that
camp I said this is not the time to to
learn something new or try to like you
know change your brain it's the time to
use the fact that hopefully you've done
things to build resilience in your brain
already and you're going to use up that
you're going to use that up now
basically um so for me it happened a bit
accidentally so I kind of took up
opportunities and I think for a good
three months or so I didn't do anything
new I just did what I had to and I
actually dialed down and made it like
you know I'm not going to do more than
than what I really have to and then it
became sort of spring summer in the UK
and my husband really wanted to play
tennis and he's much better than me so
we decided we would would buy one of
these tennis ball machines that throws
the ball at you so that he could he
could play um by himself and I left it
too late so they'd all been sold out so
I sort of reluctantly said we I'll you
know I'll come to the court with you but
you're going to have to give me lessons
because I'm just no way as good as you
and then I experienced that absolute
Rush of neuroplasticity just seeing
yourself getting better at something
each time and you know sort of seeing
that progress and I could it was it was
physical it felt more like
neuroplasticity in progress than like
when I learned language or and I have to
say my cooking has massively improved in
the last year as well not and it's you
know not out of choice I've cooked three
meals a day for most of a year um so I
think seeing those little opportunities
of where you've made changes and what
you have become better at and focusing
on that rather than necessarily thinking
you know I'm going to take on some new
learning but like I always say a new
language or a musical instrument are the
best things and
I've had a piano keyboard I'm ashamed to
say it was my Christmas present the year
before last and it's been Gathering dust
and so I was saying on sort of social
media and stuff that I'd love to to
learn it but obviously now I can't get a
teacher you know in your home or
whatever and then somebody told me about
this app called flowy and it's
completely changed my life it's amazing
um so you just use the app on your phone
it tells you what to do on the piano it
listens back to what you play and you
know that's been really wonderful too
but I think
the message here is that it's so
important to go with what you actually
want to do that's enjoyable rather than
forcing yourself to try to create
neuroplasticity in your brain because
actually then it just has the opposite
effect what would be some addictions
habits behaviors that people are
suffering from today that that is an
example of this yeah so I like the way
you framed that as not good good or bad
we could say positive or negative or you
know just productive nonproductive um
and so through my work which is which is
very very varied so you know I work with
Executives mostly in financial services
I teach at MIT Sloan um I work with a
very different demographic through my
social media and through you know people
that read my book and listen to my
podcast but I see the same issues
surfacing across the board and this is
based on the dopaminergic Pathways in
the brain which are related to
motivation so motivation is um the
neurological mechanism that makes us
seek something that's good for us but
motivation and addiction are on a
spectrum so something that used to be
good for us if we overdo it or we're
doing it and somehow it's starting to
actually not have the same effect so we
have to do more of a certain action to
get the same reward that can become
destructive and obviously drugs and
alcohol are examples of that that
everyone will understand but I'm talking
about things like
being a workaholic so working excessive
hours over exercising um particularly in
a really high intensity way that
actually creates more cortisol and
stress in the
body um so basically screen time and the
story that I hear with this is it's
really important in my job to be
responsive I always reply to emails
straight away and I get rewarded for
that and then that can at the other end
of the spectrum be I'm constant
scrolling social media I'm working
across time zones I'm looking at my
phone in the middle of the night so you
can see with all of those things how you
know being having a good work ethic is
great but working excessive hours and
damaging your health and your
relationships isn't intuition is the
lessons that you picked up along the way
that you're not conscious of but they're
still stored in your nervous
system and so the less conscious you are
of them the deeper their pushed into the
nervous system so there's a process
called hebbian learning named after the
neuroscientist Donald Hebb and that
is it's basically you know neurons that
fire together wire together but it's
that the things that you've learned
today like things that you've learn by
speaking with me that's going to be very
front of mind and kind of just in like
little Pathways that are just kind of
connecting up with each other but stuff
that you learned when you were five like
when you put your hand in a fire and it
burnt you and you never ever want to do
that again that's deep down you're not
really conscious of that but you know
and other things maybe that you don't
recall so we believe that your that
wisdom gets pushed from the outer
cortex into the lyic system which is the
emotional system of the brain into the
brain stem into the spinal cord and into
the gut neurons and that's why they
sometimes call it gut instinct because
it's that feeling of knowing something
but not knowing why you know it um but
it's actually to do with the fact that
you have wisdom and
experience that is it's in it's it's
embodied in you but you're not conscious
of it necessarily 75% of the brain is
made up of water and of the solid matter
60% is made up of fat so the focus
should be on good fats and hydrating
Foods in your diet so that's like oily
fish if you eat fish um eggs if you eat
eggs um and then avocado nuts seeds
olive oils um obviously leafy greens but
particularly hydrating foods like
cucumber melon and then the best foods
for your brain are dark skinned Foods so
like beets black beans eggplant and the
good news is that dark chocolate over
80% and organic coffee count in that too
because in the skins of dark Foods
there's a uh something something called
anthocyanins which are really strong
antioxidants that support your brain
protect it from inflammation but also
support growth of new
cells um so I just try to eat as many of
those things as I can also because of
the gut brain connection fermented foods
so like Cafe kombucha sauerkraut kimchi
um and then you know just just eating
around that the sort of right proportion
of protein fat and carbs so just not too
much carbs but some whole grain you need
to make serotonin for example um the
hydration equation is half a liter of
water for every 30 pounds of your body
weight so you need to work out what that
ideal number is and then see where
you're at at the moment and if there's a
big gap just increase it by one glass of
water per day over a sort of you know
one to two week period otherwise you're
going to notice you're going to the
bathroom a lot more can we spend a
moment on sleep posture yeah of course I
actually did a real for you on um
Instagram yeah and I was saying that the
best position for cleaning out your
brain overnight which is a very
active forcible flushing process of
getting rid of the sort of toxins that
build up through the wear and te of
daily life um and this process takes 7
to 8 hours is lying on your side so
basically left or right side but that's
better than lying on your front or your
back and it's something to do with the
positioning of the vessels in your neck
um so basically the fluid that the brain
sits in which also is you know there are
ventricles in the brain that forces
toxins out overnight and if your head is
to the side then it's easier to expel
them it's called the glymphatic system
in the brain but basically it goes into
your lymphatic system and then gets
expelled from your body yeah so I've
actually I love it Sid sleeping yeah I
have a special pillow that makes me
sleep on my side oh really what is it
it's a temple memory foam pillow that's
got a ridge so that it fits nicely into
the side of your head and neck and
shoulder the sort of the intentionality
of what you do so you can do the same
thing like okay so intermittent fasting
is a great example there's a huge
difference between people who say oh I
forget to eat breakfast and people who
eat like me which is only between 12:00
noon and 8:00 p.m. every day because of
the intense
it actually has a different effect on
your body yeah so it's like your body's
like burning more because you're
intentionally doing that or you're
losing more weight or something I won't
go so far as to say it's burning more or
you're losing more weight but there's so
again in Neuroscience there's a
difference
between um intentional mind wandering
and just slipping off into daydreaming
and so if you slip off into daydreaming
that means your attention isn't the best
and it's actually kind of a bad sign in
terms of your focus and your
concentration but if you intentionally
let your mind wand then actually that
leads to more creative thinking the
longer we have been experiencing
something the more deeply entrenched it
is in our brain and that's why the
neural Pathways that relate to things
like the values that we hold the roles
that we play in our family and Social
Circle how boundaried we are or not the
expectations that we place on ourselves
eles and the secrets that we keep can be
so deeply embedded in the neural
architecture of our brains that we're
not really aware of how much they drive
our Behavior so essentially these are
subconscious or non-conscious beliefs
that drive our thinking processes and
then drive the actions that we take in
the real
world the good news is that through
neuroplasticity you can choose
Sustainable New behaviors that will over
overwrite those old neural Pathways that
you have in your
brain it's important to remember that
neuroplasticity can work for good or for
bad so you also need to be so mindful of
what you're exposing your brain to
everything you see on the TV reading the
news the people that you meet and the
emotions that you experience and the
thoughts that you let go round and round
in your
brain now there's a process for
embedding sustainable Behavior change in
your brain and that starts with raised
awareness so you really have to bring
from non-conscious to conscious what it
is that's driving your behaviors and
thinking processes at the
moment you can do that through
meditation journaling therapy or just
talking to good
friends once you've identified what
might be holding you back from success
what barriers you may be placing in
front of yourself or just old patterns
of thinking and behavior that no longer
serve you you can start to focus
attention on certain situations or
relationships where these behaviors tend
to show themselves up at first it's
important just to notice where you could
have done something differently rather
than jumping straight into
action once youve spent some time
reflecting on this and you have a few
good examples of ways that you think or
behave that you'd like to change you can
start the third step of deliberate
practice which is choosing a new way of
Behaving or choosing a new thought or
positive affirmation or Mantra that you
can use to overwrite Old unhelpful
thought patterns and then deliberately
practicing these actions and thoughts
until they become so strongly embedded
in your brain that they become the
default pathway for your brain to send
energy
along the more you repeat something and
the more emotional intensity there is
associated with it the more likely the
neurons are to wire together and form
new neural Pathways that make you the
new you and give you the best life that
you can have and this is really from the
root level up it's not superficial
Behavior change it's changing the way
that you now do
things the final part of that process is
about accountability we all have so many
good intentions but we don't always see
them through and that's why an app like
living ashram or a buddy that you're
going through this Behavior change
process with really helps you to be much
more successful than if you just have
vague thoughts about changing a way of
being or
acting the evidence from really
committing to a behavior change like
this is so strong that even the field of
research around epigenetics which is the
effect of the environment on your genes
shows that if you think in a different
way act in a new way give up lifestyle
behaviors that are actually holding you
back from being the best self that you
can be things like stress smoking
drinking not exercising eating badly
that you can actually change the
expression of your genes so we all have
um parts of our genes that can be
switched on or off so even if we have
certain um likelihoods of getting
certain diseases or living to a certain
age through our thoughts and our
behaviors we can change some of those
outcomes comes pretty
incredible one way to approach this is
through positive
visualization so you can visualize
yourself healthy and well and you can
really take that to the core of you and
see yourself exhibiting these good
behaviors and visualize the outcome that
that would have for you in the
future another way of priming your brain
to make sure that you stay accountable
to these goals that you really want to
reach is to create what I call an action
board
now this is like a vision board it's a
collage of images metaphorical or
literal that represent all the things
that you really want in life but the
scientific part says that you also have
to take goal orientated action towards
making these things come true you can't
just sit at home and fantasize about
them coming true so if you create an
action board you look at it every day
you visualize it coming true and you
take the actions whether it's from the
brain Body Connection actions that you
committed to or something to do with a
longer more sustainable Behavior change
and you keep doing them you'll see the
results rolling in and this really comes
back to living ashram's motto of root
level up whole human approach to wealth
to health wealth and well-being um so
it's about really committing and seeing
that through in every aspect of your
body your thoughts your emotions and
your spirit if your brain has seen
something or experienced it through
mental
rehearsal
then when it comes across something
similar in real life it's less
threatening so uncertainty is the most
threatening thing to your brain anything
new is a huge threat to your brain which
is kind of counter to neuroplasticity
right because with
neuroplasticity I make myself do
something new every year so I've learned
several languages really yeah how many
languages do you know now
um I've learned five in my life I'm not
going to
pretend um are you fluent in any yes I
was very lucky I was brought up
bilingual in English and an Indian
language and then from the age of nine I
learned French at school wow um and then
as an adult I learned three other
languages at different times um probably
not so good at those
ones um yeah so during the
pandemic I I actually made a statement
in the beginning which was don't
necessarily put pressure on yourself to
like start a new career or learn a
language then it went on for longer than
we all thought it would um so I was
actually on an Instagram live saying
that I'd always wanted to learn the
piano and somebody sent me a DM and said
Dr Tara you can use the Floy app to
teach yourself piano Floy huh yeah it's
a really really cool app and um I've
been gifted a piano keyboard for
Christmas by my husband I I am ashamed
to say a year or two earlier and never
used it um so in the pandemic I did I
did use the Floy app and teach myself um
now you know how to play
piano more than Twinkle Twinkle Little
Star exactly yeah yeah yeah and um my
husband gave me tennis lessons and then
I thought okay if I can learn piano and
I can learn tennis and I can see how
much I improveed and I can see the
muscle memory from when I played tennis
from when I was at at High School
can I apply that
to looking at life through a happier
lens so it's a natural default for all
of us to you know loss aversion is one
of the biggest gearings of the brain and
it's essential to survival loss aversion
yeah so avoiding loss and uncertainty
like I said we don't like that so we
like things to be safe we like them to
be the same you know we like to know
what's going to happen and and equally
we you know the brain wants to look out
for danger to protect us and during the
pandemic I'd been speaking for a few
years about having a sabatical and a few
people said to me oh now you can have a
sabatical and I said you know I'm locked
up at home I can't travel I can't see my
friends I can't hug my stepson it's not
a sabatical it's not the sabatical I
dreamed of and also the mental health
requirements were
so vast that I felt I had to do my piece
and really you know speak to that
through Instagram through zoom and try
to help people so I was actually busier
with work than ever before sure trying
to help people yeah but I did start you
know I saw a lot of relationship
breakups I saw a lot of people get sick
you know a lot of people that I
personally knew died during the pandemic
and it was easy to start to feel like to
focus on things like you can't see
people people you can't travel and I
didn't I didn't want to see myself go
down that
road so I actually I got a coach you
know I believe in having therapy having
coaching having supervision love it I
love it um and I worked on on that and
she actually said to me why can't you
apply neuroplasticity to being
happier and because it's intangible it's
you know you can make a vision board
with a house and you know a a dream
holiday day and vacation and all that
for the material world exactly but how
do you create one for the emotional
world I think there are and that's why
imagery is important because it can
evoke a feeling yes um but I remember
the moment I was standing sort of at the
door to my garden and a really small
nice thing had happened and I thought
isn't that lovely and and I I actually
checked myself and I thought I notice
when something goes wrong all the time I
don't always acknowledge when something
goes right or is really good and happy
and so I could tell that I had I had
changed that I was noticing those things
you didn't notice that before I mean I'm
sure I did sometimes with like big
things the threats have changed from
physical to psychological or social um
although that threat also existed
because we could only really Thrive as
part of a tribe in the cave and that was
literally for physical warmth as well as
affection and you know looking after
each other's children and sharing with
responsibilities now there aren't as
many any in that way anyway physical
threats to our sa our safety or our life
but the social threat of being rejected
being lonely being abandoned um that's
still very very strong in our wiring um
and then other things because obviously
now we have money for example that the
idea of losing your job losing your
lifestyle those have become you know
sort of potential social threats to your
safety as well and you know there's so
many more
but I would say that financial and
relational have become the biggest
threats to our safety so I think obvious
examples of that are staying in a
relationship where you're not really
happy but you think well it's better
than being single again kind of thing
um and because that wiring has been
there for so long and of course in
Lacy's work she talks about wiring that
has been there since childhood for us as
individuals and we have you know made it
very clear that the longer an issue has
been there the harder it is to um bring
it from subconscious to conscious and
then deal with it this is even beyond
that this is for generations and
Millennia so it's a very strong default
and it it's really every decision that
you make is based on is the world a safe
place can I do this and still be healthy
and happy and you mentioned a specific
which is not watching the news well I
don't know any neuroscientist that I'm
friends with who watches the news and
and that's the reason because because
we're wired to default to loss aversion
if we continually tell our brain that
there's danger out there there's bad
people out there there's accidents out
there you will not want to take the
healthy risks that you could to make
your life better because you're too
aware of the possible dangers do you
remember I mentioned the um I I
mentioned six ways of thinking I may not
have classified them as the brain model
you said what's the source and I said
it's your fully integrated brain power
and so I I put that into six categories
which are mastering your emotions
knowing yourself which is the brain Body
Connection trusting your gut which is
intuition making good decisions it it's
logic logic has to be in there but it's
just one of the six um staying motivated
and resilient to reach your goals and
then the final one which is kind of the
culmination of those five is um creating
the life that you desire so in that
model I talk about using all of the
different ways that you have to think to
to to manifest real world outcomes but
I'd also like to say it this point that
I was one of those people who was told
at school that I wasn't creative because
I wasn't good at
Art and so I wanted to my head master or
no brother brother John was it a veryan
Catholic High School sent me to the
Headmaster saying I couldn't be this
possibly be this bad at Art I must be
painting this way just to piss him off
oh and look look what you've created
right I'm still Shake though if you give
me a paintbrush it literally it and
someday I will get to challenge myself
on that but that like the root beer is
still in
me well do you remember that quote from
the book
um if somebody tells you you can't paint
by all means paint yes um so I think you
know I want to give that to you as a as
a gift um but yeah I mean things like
that stay with you for ages if you're
like 11 and you're told that you're not
creative I believed I wasn't creative
till I was 35 I fully believed I was not
creative and all my friends are creative
creative in the obvious sense of the
word and I sort of thought isn't it
strange how all my friends are creative
but I'm not and there were a few friends
that said but you are but I was so shut
off to believing that that was true that
I didn't even question it or say what do
you mean or you know explore it um so
for me there was like a bang kind of you
know a crisis moment that changed
everything but one of the reasons I
wrote The Source is that that it
shouldn't have to be like that we could
you know we can all bring that into our
lives without necessarily having a
crisis so so I wanted to reframe
creativity and just make it about
creating your own life um
and and so man so manifestation is
basically believing that you have more
agency around creating you know what you
want in your life rather than that life
just happens to you um I totally
understand that it feels like that for
people a lot of the time um and you know
I use this analogy where I say if if
you're going on a joury a car journey
and um would you rather be the person in
the driving seat choosing the
destination and how you get there or are
you happy to be in the passenger seat
and just be driven around not know where
you're going and you know the the route
that you take and so a lot for for a lot
of people life can feel like you're in
the passenger seat and understanding
Neuroscience is about putting yourself
in the driver's seat so the
manifestation part is how much can you
contribute to actually bringing into
your life the things that you really
really want and so it's a bit of a gray
area because to me it overlaps with
Magnetic desire which is something that
you really really really want so there
has to be a strong emotional component
to it and then the actions that draw
that into your life so I'm not one of
those people that says if you visualize
something or make a vision board or you
know imagine an ideal future that you
should just wait for it to come true
because you thought about it I'm very
much about doing the actions that um
move move you know progress you towards
that goal becoming true and so um the
science around manifestation and
magnetic desire and vision boards is a
three-step concept in the brain which is
selective attention selective filtering
and value
tagging and basically we're bombarded
with so much information all the time
everything we smell hear see everyone we
meet that the brain naturally filters
most of that out and um brings our
attention to the things that are
relevant for our survival tags those
things in order of importance and
there's both a logical and an emotional
component to why certain things are
important to us so you can imagine if
you're trying to hold down the day job
if you're trying to put food on the
table that that filtering process
happens quite automatically and it's not
thinking what's the best thing that
could ever happen to me in my life how
do I really want my life to look like in
five years time it's not doing that it's
just doing how do I survive like in the
next short
term so um paying attention to
manifestation and one of the mediums for
doing that as a vision board is a way of
priming your brain to notice and grasp
opportunities that might otherwise have
passed you
by any best advice on overcoming and
facing fear that gets in the way of the
action that's needed to fulfill my
action board yeah I actually want to
take that back a stage CU something I
hear quite often is that people have
selected the images laid them out on the
board but haven't glued them down yet
and I think this is this person's
obviously gone further which is great
but it's kind of on the same Spectrum
usually it comes back to a feeling of
lack of deserving of the of the image so
the thing that you want and what I will
say from a neuroscience point of view is
that fear and uncertainty are actually
the worst state for your brain to be in
if if you take a step
forward what you find out quite quickly
is that even if something doesn't work
out that feeling is less bad for your
brain than the fear of uncertainty you
mentioned nature and looking at the
stars and
stuff what's inherently good about
nature yeah so this has really come up
as a big one in the last few years and I
don't I'm not sure if it's coincidental
with the pandemic and having been locked
up or or locked up but also had more
opportunity to maybe commune with nature
than we did in our hectic Lifestyles
before but the brain benefits of time
spent in nature are
massive
and I whenever I'm asked a question that
I don't necessarily factually know the
answer too straight away always take it
back to Evolution there's a reason that
our brains were wide in a certain way
and and when we first became you know
homo sapien
we walked on the Savannah we we walked
in the land we we ate what we could hunt
fish or har or harvest and so our
relationship with nature was was you
know we were dependent on it but it was
also a huge threat to us floods storms
you know fires um it's the symbiotic
relationship and what we've done through
Agriculture and construction is just
move ourselves further and further away
from that and even if you just think one
like super scientific example of that is
that the quality and diversity of our
gut Flora has diminished so much since
we lived in the cave it's it's like
reduced by I don't want to get the
number wrong but it's a shocking Factor
like hundred
hundreds
um and agriculture's contributed to that
antibiotics have contributed to that to
that like obviously antibiotics save
lives and you know it's been an amazing
advance for us as humans
but um the fact that we eat food that's
not as diverse as it used to
be that we don't necessarily eat those
Natural Things the Prebiotic and
Probiotic foods and supplements that
allow our gut bacteria to flourish and
we eat so much processed
food um and that stress alcohol and
antibiotics will damage our gut
microbiome
that's one of the huge consequences of
of um having moved away from
nature and people ask all sorts of
questions that we don't know all the
answers to yet about why do we have more
diseases like me like Ms like autism
like add and some of the answers lie in
that disconnection from nature and what
that's done to how that's shaped our
bodies and our brains right um and how
we live as a result of that just take
one minute to look at a leaf or a petal
or a squirrel or something like that's
like close up right in front of you in
great
detail and then take one minute to look
at a really large tree or building or a
cloud in the
distance and just see how that resets
your nervous system so there's a couple
of so that that's basically taking
yourself away from sharp Focus to a wide
Vista which is part of like living in
nature and on the Savannah is that we we
love having an uninterrupted view of the
Horizon it's really restful for the
brain oh yeah okay and then as well as
like 10 deep breaths you can just do
like you can take you can do a sharp
intake of breath and just do like a
really long sigh as well that's a nice
little way to reset your nervous system
the scientific version of that really is
that the way that you think determines
what happens in your
life and again again you know it's
something I've been speaking about for
so long but it's more crucial than ever
now because it's so easy to think
negatively now it's so easy to feel down
to feel out of control um to hear what
everybody else is saying and just get
swept up in that and that's why things
like the journaling and the affirmation
and the action board are so important
because they can really help to keep you
focused on the fact that the way that
you think is going to make the
difference between surviving and
thriving
and again hopefully we all have a bit
more time now to really do what's called
metacognition which is think about our
thinking so not just let the outside
world happen to us but take more agency
over the way that we think and react to
things so finally I just wanted to say
that what the science really points at
with all those tips behind us is that
your mental resilience or your inner
strength whatever you like to call it is
the key differenti in terms of how
people are going to deal and cope even
in the same circumstances so you know
there's there's you that will struggle
with something and then there's the best
you that will get through it that will
inspire others and will come out feeling
better and stronger and I believe in
that you and the science really backs it
up so please believe that you're
remarkable that you can do things that
you never thought you could do before
and let's all do it together in
community think we've said a lot there's
one thing that I didn't write about in
the book as much as I would have liked
to and that's
forgiveness um and actually you reminded
me about that by talking about Hawaii um
and because I did some research into the
ho opopo when I was writing the book I'm
sure you know all time favorite yeah I'm
sure you know about it way better than
me and I don't want to you know to do it
a disj dustice but when I struggled with
forgiveness I asked so many people
people I read about it I you know
listened to meditations and and you know
a version of the Hawaiian um
forgiveness meditation was what was what
really worked for me so um it's very
simple the version that I do is to think
of the person that you're struggling to
forgive and say um thank you I love you
I'm sorry I forgive you I release you
but you have to keep saying it until you
mean it and it can be hard at times when
you get
there it changes your life what are some
ways that people can can start
meditating if it's something that
they've never
tried well the easiest way to start if
you've never tried is to use one of
these apps so there are apps like
headspace Cal buddify and and many many
more um unplug so find one that you like
you know if you like the voice of the
person that helps just put your your
earphones in and um listen to the voice
for 10 minutes and just kind of you know
let them guide you it took me nine or 10
months of doing that before I could do
it without the app so you know it does
take some time but then if you don't
want to use an app because let's say
you're choosing not to use technology
then do something like um like I said
focusing on your breath as one and maybe
just counting how long your breaths are
and trying to make the inhale and the
exhale pretty equal um otherwise you can
do open monitoring of your thoughts
which is just sit quietly for 10 minutes
and just see what thoughts come into
your mind and just let them come and go
um you can also do um intentional mind
wandering so you can just sit down and
ask yourself a whatif question and then
just let your mind go in all different
directions um or you can do focused
attention which is picking a sound or an
object and just focusing on that um the
thing I'm really into at the moment is
vadic meditation which is use of a
mantra and you know there there's
evidence that a lot lot of very
successful Executives use vadic
meditation or Transcendental Meditation
um and that's like the most effective
for mental health and brain
performance but personally I don't I
think you know mindfulness is an
umbrella term and meditation is one of
the things that falls under that like
yoga one of the things I've really
cultivated in this last year and you
know like you said there's time for
introspection also we're just stuck at
home most of the time is creating a
patchwork quilt of mindfulness
throughout my whole day
so I do my viic meditation first thing
in the morning when I wake up like in
bed but then throughout the day I do
mindful eating if I go outside I do
mindful
walking um I do do yoga as well and then
when it's kind of meal times or just you
know windown time in the evening I'm
very and throughout the day actually I'm
really really conscious of paying
attention to my loved ones so even if
I'm in the middle of a really important
email email and my husband walks in
whereas before I would have been like oh
you know I'm in the middle of something
and he's interrupting me I always say to
myself now okay what is the most
important thing is this email more
important than your marriage so I stop
in the middle of the email and I turn
and I pay my full attention and I'm not
holding my phone at the same time and
I'm not thinking about other things at
the same time so with that you find that
you're actually doing a lot of
mindfulness through the day and it's
just a matter of building those things
up and kind of you know being very aware
that that's your intention is to be
mindful because you made it this far in
a video I want to celebrate you most
people start and don't finish most
people never actually follow through
most people say they want something but
they don't ever do the work to actually
get it but you are different you are
special believe Nation you made it here
all the way to the end and I love you so
as a special celebration if you put a
hasht believe down in the comments Below
on this video I will showcase you and
celebrate you somewhere on the screen in
a future video because you are awesome
for some incredible Mel Robins
motivation check the video right there
next to me I think you'll love it
continue to believe and I'll see you
there do not sleep with your phone
because the one decision everybody makes
that kills your productivity kills your
focus tanks your mental health is before
you get yourself right you grab your
phone and check in with the world